okay y'all so i went out into the
trenches today
okay it wasn't really the trenches i
went out into the streets of london and
i decided to interview people about this
sign now the point of this interview was
i wanted to see if people believed in
equal rights for men i mean come on
y'all if women have the right not to be
mothers then shouldn't men have the
right not to be fathers i thought this
would be an easy agree everyone's on the
same team but i guess you'll see what
happens
we don't have any pro-lifers here right
we don't have any pro right now we're
talking about men's rights
okay okay okay so so what's your name
ariana ariana i'm pearl nice to meet you
nice to meet you rainbow nice to meet
you nice to meet you
if a woman has a choice of whether or
not she wants to be a mother right
should a man have the choice of whether
or not he wants to be a father
in the name of equality yeah
yeah
i mean
everyone has their own choices of what
they want to do with their life so i
mean if a woman has
their own choice of whether they want to
be a mother or not i guess obviously
if the dad doesn't want to be in the
life of their child then
that's up to them what do you think i'm
looking confused i thought we were
talking about pro-life approach voices
no so so what we're talking about so if
i if i want to get an abortion in the uk
right i can get an abortion up to six
months
but if a man says i don't want to be a
father he's still on the hook for child
support and depending on how many kids
there are it's between 13 and 20 percent
so that incentivizes women to get kids
off of rich guys for example in the u.s
the nba players had a statement being
issued out
that
to flush their condoms because girls
were stealing them and so if we get the
right not to be mothers like shouldn't
they get the right not to be fathers so
they could sign off all their rights and
sign off on child support they don't owe
anything
i mean if the father doesn't want to be
in the child's life then like force them
to do what they and they don't think the
child would deserve that then yeah
it has bad effects on
the child on the child essentially
because that causes like psychological
harm and stuff
but
at the end of the day i mean it is up to
the the father but at the end of the day
like the child's life
if the child's brought into the world
like your child's life kind of matters
and whether your child's going to be a
happy child or not or disrupted child
that's kind of up to whether you have
one
um
one kind of parent parental figure in
their life and or two yeah and i'm not
saying he shouldn't be in the la in
their life i'm just saying in the name
of equality it should be even so like he
shouldn't owe child support but i think
we agree then
like he shouldn't be on the hook for
child support because a guy can go to
jail for not paying child support
they can't they can seize your they can
seize your
know that's a bit assets
i didn't know i didn't know that that's
just a bit
that's what i don't know
i don't know i don't honestly don't know
what the laws are like in the uk i'm not
really i mean i'm from here i didn't
know that that's quite shocking that's
i don't know that's yeah
but it seems like we're all on the same
page you'd be okay with a financial
abortion for men
i wouldn't want like if i don't want my
i want my father's well my child's
father to
like if he doesn't want to be in the
father so i didn't deserve whether they
meant to pay i wouldn't want them to pay
then at that point you know yeah if he
doesn't want to be that i don't want him
to like be forced to kind of pay for
everything to do the child however like
me having that experience of like
growing up with two parents and stuff
it's definitely been
a lot better than
people that i know that have grown up
like without a father and without a
mother like it's a lot different for
them do you think it's better if people
are married before they have kids oh
oh [ __ ] happens
yeah stuff i mean some people prefer to
be in like a very committed like locked
down relationship before they have
children but i mean there's a lot of
people that
aren't married but have kids
what do you think what was the question
again do you think people it's better
for the child the children if the
parents are married before they have
them
no i mean i don't
i don't see the any the impact
i don't see the impact of like
because there's a lot of people like my
parents weren't married before they had
all their kids and
they only got married
probably before their last two kids and
had about five before that and all of us
have turned out fine all of us have you
know stayed like that and whatever
there's a lot of kids out there that
their parents aren't married per se and
i don't think that has an impact on you
you think it's more important just have
both parents in the home
yeah well to have both parents there
it's more obviously ideally but ideally
i think just in those times that we are
now
you can still
you can still you can parent
you can still raise a child you don't
need obviously it's ideal and
everyone wants hard it's harder
obviously yeah but i don't think that
you can still do it it's still possible
you've seen there's so many people who
have like raised their child as a single
parent and they've turned out fine yeah
and they're strong in their all the
qualities you want in a child but
statistically your kid's more at risk if
you at like every statistical advantage
disadvantage obviously yeah but like
it's life i mean
everything you won't get everything you
won't always get the marriage the dream
marriage you won't always sometimes you
have a kid before marriage and if
so what happens you try your best and
yeah obviously statistically yeah you'd
better have two parents and two figures
in the house in the home but
do you think once you get married it's
about the kids happiness and not yours
i think that should be a balance
obviously you put your kids before
yourself
but
i think even before you're married like
and you have kids before you're married
you essentially put all your energy and
stuff into your child and making your
child happy and like having the best
life for your child but there has to be
a balance between
your happiness to take over yourself yes
your personal happiness and you know
your side of life
as well as your child's side of life
there has to be that balance but
yeah essentially like
having two parents there and having one
parent there i think nowadays you know
it's not really
too big of a deal having a single parent
but then like obviously back in the day
like years and years ago like when our
parents were younger it would always be
seen as like the two parents it was seen
as like you have to have two parents
with your child it's better for your
children blah blah blah obviously it's
better but like
it's more ideal to have two parents
rather than one because
yeah that's but i mean that's like
stereotypical of like it's better and
more ideal to have
two parents but nowadays it's like you
can raise a child by yourself and be a
single parent like i've seen it alone
we're doing public interviews now okay
hi
hi public interviews hi
[Music]
you wanna be interviewed we asked the
public in london their opinion on
certain topics
hi what's your name ellie
what'd you say ellie
do you have any social media you want to
plug no it's fine yeah so today's topic
her body her choice right
do you sense women have the right not to
be mothers if they don't want to should
men have the right not to be fathers if
they don't want to
yes in
for example
i'm not sure how her body her choice um
well what's the connection here because
that's about abortion well let's leave
that aside women have the right to give
up the child for adoption yes and yes
that is mentioned absolutely at the same
right to give up their child for
adoption
um because that would be really like for
like when we talk about the rights
i don't think draw parallel between
abortion and and and
men not being fathers but certainly if
you're talking about giving up the child
adoption or
disavowing yeah then men should have the
same right as women and women do have
that right why don't you think it's
comparable abortion and
child support abortion is a different
question
it's whether the woman has a right to
abort the child or not i mean even if
you might
you might agree that a woman has a right
not to
have to physically support
with her body i mean physically
obviously everything we do is physically
about me you might agree the woman
doesn't need to physically um give life
to the child
and yet you would still
think that the woman should have to feed
her child if the child is born and vice
versa you could think that the woman
shouldn't be able to kill the child
because it's it's a human being and yet
he could still support the right of the
woman or the man to give her the child
for adoption so i don't think he can i
mean
he can he can be on one side of one
argument on the other side the other
arguments basically
are you are you pro-life um yes that's
as i'd say broadly speaking yes do you
think it should be illegal all of the
time um
probably the best argument could be made
for for
when it was uh non-consensual to begin
with
i think the best argument for adoption
for abortion
is that um with a famous argument that
you know you imagine you wake up
someone's done operation and you've been
hooked up to
another person it might be there's that
a nobel prize scientist and
your kidney is supporting him and
if you unplug yourself from him or hurt
them what percent of abortions do you
think are um in the case of rubber
incest or grape grape youtube
i have no idea it's actually less than
one percent okay fine i'm saying that
probably i'm saying
broadly speaking i'm pro-life because uh
i think there is there is a there is
another life and certainly there
shouldn't be i can obviously i'm not
going to run away with it if you want to
mean it is easier
okay
um
certainly there shouldn't be an option
of aborting just because
um
in the same way in fact in the same way
the argument is often made if you ever
go on any forums for example certainly
feminist forums but even not necessarily
feminist forums um you'd say
fathers who don't want to support are
called deadbeats and and really maligned
and so look if you don't have a child
then either you know wear condom or
abstain tie your um
have the snip
all these things all these arguments and
the same could be applied for women if
you don't if
what you you want to be certain that
you're not going to become pregnant and
and you know um have to support the the
the child when it's born the life you
know give give support um life support
to this child then don't have sex
but and it's interesting because 40
percent of abortions the woman has had
two or more abortions and it doesn't
track if they have an abortion in the
future
so only 60 of abortions are their first
time and it doesn't track what they're
doing in the future so it seems like
it's becoming a form of contraception
rather than a worst case scenario
i'm not sure what you want i mean that
wasn't a question there you no i was
just telling you this style i was just
wanting to get your reaction to it okay
i mean it's interesting i i mean i'll
take your stats at face value i'll have
to believe you because i'm just check
that but even voicing it
it's hardly a form of contraception
generally speaking you get the morning
after pill
they're much easier ways of
contraception even after the fact i'm
saying it's being used as a form of
contraception like rather that like when
i a lot of people think like it should
be a last case resort
and right now we're seeing it being used
as a form of contraception and you can
see that because 40 percent of women are
keep getting them over and over again
and that doesn't include women that have
them in the future
what do you mean a formal contraception
why would they
why would they have an abortion why not
just for example
either be on the pill use the condom or
take the morning after pills i agree
that's how it should be but that's just
not what they're doing it's because it's
legal and free yeah but
no i think you're not getting what i'm
saying i'm saying
it doesn't make sense that women are
just using it because legal or free so
just using it why not because it's much
more difficult for the person
in order to have an abortion usually
we're talking about we're talking about
six eight ten twelve weeks even and
they've they've had to carry that
they've had to be pregnant for 12 weeks
already which is more difficult hard on
the body so it's hard to believe that
it's as simplistic as you're putting it
that just using its contraception there
must be something more to it a reason
why they're not uh aborting or using
morning after pill straight away or
what's happening what's changing but
it's probably a bit more complex than i
mean i can't tell you why i'm just
telling you what the data says right so
i don't know why they're not using
contraception
but like it's it's self-reported so they
ask women how many abortions they've had
before and that's what they write down
you were saying why that's the thing you
were saying why you
the data is that that women are having
multiple abortions and your analysis was
that it seemed they knew added it seemed
that they're using it as a form of
contraception well yeah because that's
that's literally what they're doing
if
if they keep getting abortions over and
over again it's a form of contraception
yes
to a degree but i'm saying it's probably
a bit more complex but what do you what
do you think i don't know i i'd really
have to think
whatever i think would be just a theory
and that need to be backed up i mean
like you can allow you could give a
guess why something is the way it is but
often it's just my bias your bias all of
our bias is
informing us why we make these analyses
but
really should be backed by by evidence
but
say overall in pro-life anyway because
and so it's often portrayed as a
you want to punish one woman for having
sex and it's not that at all it's
having sex carries the known risk of
becoming pregnant so if you engage in
activity that you know might end up with
you having to look after the
i mean really the
the real question is always when does
life begin and
that is also uh
i mean
i say personally i'm pro-life but i
they're both sides of the argument so
the one side the argument is that it's
pro-life it's a human life what then
would he call it i mean aborting means
killing it's killing a baby an unborn
child you leave it's going to grow and
95 percent of abolish by 95 of
biologists would agree that it's light
yes
of course it's life yeah but the
question is he that is their own
question the question isn't when does
life begin it's it's when personhood
begins um i
human rights um when do we call it a
person so we give it it's entitled to
all the rights and protections and
that's not not clear cut because there
is no definitive answer i mean there's
no knocker argument you say it has to
begin at conception dna or or whatever
there's no real reason you can always
argue
different
whether it's a heartbeat whether it's
birth whether it's um um
feel it what's uh
what's up i forgot the word what it
feels um
you know what i mean when i can feel
pain um
i forgot the word like brain activity
brain activity also um
oh i forgot the word when when it feels
when it feels pain it's the way people
differentiate between insects and and
animals they are not
sentient oh scientists yeah um so again
but this so the real question is when
should personhood begin i said there's
no definitive there's no
science nobody can really answer that
from from any reason it's all emotive
and
um
there's one thing i wanted to ask you
about just slit my hands
oh yeah um
let me ask you
can i because
ivf
what's your opinion in general
oh i don't know enough about ivf to
really have an opinion on it
ivf you've got you get x fertilized in
the laboratory and then
um usually might be 10 12 eggs and the
most viable one or two would be then
implanted into the woman all the others
are discarded
and i know some
and i have no idea whether christian or
not or what like from where you're
approaching it but certainly you know
some christian groups are very opposed
to idf to ivf sorry because they um
they claim that this is uh
the ones that are discarded there's
really a discarding life
it's akin to abortion so all the ten um
fertilized eggs that don't make it that
aren't implanted are then discarded so
that's the same as aborting
yeah i don't really have an opinion on
it um no i'm not with like a christian
organization or anything i just have a
youtube channel okay what is that what
what's your turn oh just pearly though
pearly things yeah just pearly things
but thank you for sitting down i
appreciate it thank you very much so
today we're asking the question
it's her body her choice right we have
the right not to be mothers right 100
yeah so yeah so i was about to say i've
got a strong opinion about it because i
don't really want kids and i can just
imagine like
how horrible it would be if you don't
have a choice
like do you know like get rid of the
baby so the question is should men have
the right then not to be fathers
so if a woman gets pregnant and he says
i i want to renounce paying child
support
would you support that so he can sign
off all of his rights and leave it with
the mother
yeah because we get the right to get rid
of the kid if we want shouldn't he have
the same right in the name of like
equality that's a tough one because i
guess it that would be first um because
it's the same as the mum giving up the
child but then it's not really in their
body so i don't know how different it is
really so um
because the problem we're having is it
incentivizes women to get kids off of
rich guys
so for example the nba has issued
statements telling players to flush
their condoms because girls will steal
them because they know if they get a kid
off of them they they're entitled to
child support for 18 years i always say
okay i didn't know that yeah
and even drake i don't know if you heard
about when he put hot sauce in his
condom i know yeah the girl tried to sue
him over it [ __ ]
that's crazy actually yeah so it's like
when we're seeing things like that it
begs the question like should men have
the right not to be a father too and you
would say yeah 100 to be honest yeah
okay well we agree then thanks for
stopping
a man a man who abandons his child as a
deadbeat dad correct
um not really there are like
do you want me to elaborate there there
are like many
conditions that
allow for
for that to be to be possible and
morally permissible in in most cases
um it's to do with uh ties in a lot with
poverty
um but you know
i don't know if the label of debbie that
dad is like all-encompassing i think
selective cases maybe sorry i meant
society calls them a deadbeat dad
correct 100 i think that's something
that's yeah pretty well known it's
so if a mother abandons her child why
don't and why do we call it the right to
choose well i don't really see that as
abandonment because because obviously
when when we're talking about the idea
of a deadbeat dad uh we're talking about
a child that's uh that's that's
you know uh been been born raised by a
single mother in in that instance um but
a a woman abandoning her child um
that that's not referred to as as the
right to choose that's they're different
things if a woman
left their child after their child was
born
then if if they're not being cooled out
then you can you can make that argument
what about adoption what what about
adoption that's that's also the right to
choose right so i'm saying like even if
a woman gives up her child we don't call
her a deadbeat mom
even after it's born oh see sure yeah
sure okay yeah so i'm asking why do you
think that is why do i think that is um
possibly because i think that there
needs to be
more leniency on the side of uh of women
in in that regard because i think that
uh
women who have to give their children up
for adoption uh is very different
circumstances in the majority of cases
from a man uh uh you know uh leaving the
leaving the family home or or divorcing
or separating well so i'm not why is it
different because i mean it could it
doesn't mean they were together if you
get pregnant right it just means they
were sleeping together so how is it
different if a man doesn't want to be a
father than if a woman doesn't want to
be a mother
because to me it's like it's the same
thing
sure okay and and i'll i'll follow that
line of reasoning then so let's say it
is the same thing
what what does that insinuate for you
what does insinuate what do you mean
so so you're saying that uh you think it
is the same thing you think that they
are equivalencies
so uh what what does that insinuate for
you what what does that lead on to is do
you see that as a big problem that they
are viewed the same or do you see that
as the right thing do you see that as
not not very common that they're viewed
the same well i think women are given
passes for doing the same thing that men
do
there's a reason why women are given
passes in areas where men where men
don't why because of a
pre-pre-existing
privilege that men have in in the
majority of cases
in life in society how do men have a
privilege how do men have privilege when
they're the majority of suicides when
they do the majority of hard jobs
they have to fight in wars
okay so okay
i i think that if what you're asking and
what we're going to have to talk about
is where men have privileges then we're
not going to be able to have this
argument with this this debate we're not
going to be able to talk about this
because we're just simply not on the
same level of understanding about
society as a whole if you're unable to
understand that men have privilege in
the majority of cases and that there is
an underlying privilege that all men
have by nature of a patriarchy well i'm
asking like what what stats do you have
to back that up right so so i would say
i would say like men also make up the
majority of homeless
so so how can you say that women have an
easier life
okay okay so what i just want to know
what what privilege are you talking
about okay
i'll talk about uh what i mean by
privilege i'm talking about um an
underlying uh uh
societal um condition that allows for
for men to to be paid more okay okay uh
allows for for men to to you know and
you know we talk about uh heinous crimes
uh and that's something that because of
the condition of men you see i i believe
that it's because of uh our economic
state okay that men are more likely to
be victims of a violent crime than women
hey but not a sexual violent crime
not not well i think it goes under
reported to be honest
both go under-reported don't they
because women also don't report uh at
the same level uh that they the the the
uh is the potential of the amount of
women who've been abused that was
under-reported as well doesn't it uh
i don't know i don't think i actually
might have a stat for that which is the
uh um only one in three sexual assaults
are reported to the police only well
okay so the stat that's often referred
to is that one is it one of four one in
three women or victims of sexual assault
so they actually would include if a
woman is drunk and has sex
in that stat so no that's what i'm
saying so that they they throw that stat
around a lot and it's not actually
accurate i'm gonna uh i've got my
friends here from from sweden i'm gonna
put an end to this because uh and the
reason i'm going to say that okay
is that as i've said if you're unable to
understand the the the means at which
men are privileged in society over women
you're telling me i'm oppressed
sorry are you telling me i'm oppressed
sorry what do you you're explaining my
oppression to me do you feel oppressed
no
okay well then it's not an issue for you
is it but there are many women who do
there's a lot of women that don't are we
talking globally here
are we talking what do you mean by that
well i know that i'm talking about the
western world we're in england us
okay why why why don't we take it global
why not talk globally because we're in
the uk and i'm from the us okay so in
the us do you feel that uh you you have
um the same allowances of privilege than
men i think i have more privilege than
most men
[Music]
so so the statement means right
women we have the right if we get
pregnant we have the right not to be
mothers right yeah should men then in
the name of equality have the right not
to be fathers their wallet their choice
they can sign off on child support why
no because if you had sex with a woman
you fully know well that one of the
consequences is that you will fully like
pregnant her and you have a child so you
have to look after child as that's your
responsibility your sperm your
responsibility okay you can't run away
from that okay i don't understand why
people in their mind think it's all
right to run away from the child that's
a child you're leaving them with so much
trauma having no like dad and everything
that will leave them with severe like
ideas of how they think about men
because i'm not talking about my
perspective i've seen people's
perspective with no fathers they act in
a certain way with people that have a
father like in contrast with people who
have a father and it's not right so if
you're a man
what's the question again
yeah i can see i feel like so obviously
like
mothers and fathers they're equal to
some degree yeah but i feel like like as
a mother like the like the like what
mothers experience like when they're
like pregnant when they give birth like
everything they experience it's too a
whole different degree than what like a
father would experience yeah and it's
like
like i get like mothers and fathers they
both like they they might love their
child to the same degree they might be
present
in the child's life to the same degree
but it's like what like it's it's easier
for a dad to leave than it is for a
mother to leave yeah
mother has to go through to give birth
yeah so emotional support you're meant
to be there for emotional support do you
know what i know like they're pushing
the child and i know that and i know
this is this is like okay maybe not all
guys are like this but do you know how
many men are there they're the ones that
are like oh i don't want to use a condom
why does it fit me yeah i'm too
so the argument you guys are making i
could very similarly say the same thing
to women like you choose who you sleep
with you get to pick if the guy wears a
condom or not so so to me it's like in
the name of equality shouldn't they have
the same rights we do yeah
but but no you just argue so i'm saying
like if i if if we have an accidental
pregnancy okay if i let's say i have a
man i don't i know it's shocking but but
let's say and i and i get pregnant on
accident right so neither of us planned
this we didn't we don't want this kid
but i say i i can't have an abortion
because some girls can't and he says i
don't want to be a father shouldn't he
have the same right to leave that i do
if i leave because i can give up the kid
for adoption too i think i feel like if
the woman decides to have the baby i
feel like the father he should have the
right to be like okay i don't want to be
like
in this child's life i want to leave i
feel like he should still pay the child
support like he should have to like
like he can like sign his rights away to
the child be like i'm never but the
thing is he has to promise that he'll
never come back randomly because what
fathers love to do they love to come
back maybe like 10 15 years later and
then decide okay i'm ready to be a dad
you don't get to choose when you're
ready where is the responsibility on
women though for the men we choose to
sleep with what do you mean so so like a
lot of times what i see is i see girls
that pick men to sleep with that really
aren't husbands and they're not fathers
and they know damn well they're not
husbands and they're not fathers and
they get pregnant and they wanna and
they wanna and they want like all the
sympathy and now they get a check
right and so and so the problem with the
laws the way it is is they're they're
incentivizing women to get kids off of
rich guys so i had a guy that sat down
earlier and he said i was rich and this
girl like got trapped me with a baby
because she said she was on birth
control and i understand like he should
have taken more precautions but a man
can do everything right say say drake
right you remember what happened with
drake yeah so he but he didn't right but
like let's think about it right do you
really think he didn't think to wrap it
up with the i'm gonna say cornstar like
you really think he did when he's he's
been he's a he's a player right yeah he
knows he knows she's a corn star he
probably did she probably stole it like
why do you think he's doing in the
future like stuff like that isn't okay
like definitely i i don't think that
like you know when she when she went
behind his back and tried to like
impregnate herself stuff like that isn't
okay when the whole thing is like okay
well you chose to have sex with this guy
but like because he chose to have sex
with him too we chose to have sex with
him but like consenting to sex isn't the
same as consenting to having a baby but
some women just don't want like
they might not want to have a baby but
they don't want to have abortion more
than they didn't want to have a baby do
you know what i mean right so then they
have adoption so they could still choose
not to be a mother yeah but i don't
think you understand the whole adoption
process one adoption like
them is so fast
adoption the system is so far and i can
understand like as a woman like i you
don't understand how hard it is for some
women to really give their baby away
even if they in that moment after you've
given birth you've been through these
nine months you've cried this baby like
you're holding this baby and you don't
want to give it away but you know that's
what you have to do it's a really like
difficult situation and even if you give
that baby away like a lot of the
adoption system it's so [ __ ] like it's
not it's not necessary they think that
they're giving their baby away it's like
the best possible option but that's not
always the best option and people's
argument is like how could you look to
the baby like they might not have a good
life but babies they don't even gain
consciousness until like how many months
old so a baby being a baby being aborted
the baby doesn't know that it's being a
boy if it hasn't lived do you know what
i mean yeah i feel like i'm just trying
rubbish
okay i'm just curious like just going
with this logic right do you think like
the a week before she gives pregnancy
because it's her body her choice she
should be able to have an abortion i
think i think if if it's like a week
before she's about to give birth if the
doctors tell her okay
when you give birth you're gonna like
i'm pretty sure that's not even that's
not even legal it's not even legal but
if we're like debating whether it should
be okay or not if we could do a month
right we could i'm just saying like at
what point at what point you should be
able to support the baby like early on
yes
two weeks early like you just got
pregnant yeah one to two weeks you
killed the baby right then there's no
that's not long enough though babe three
weeks
it's do you know how it takes a woman
maybe like two weeks to even figure out
that she's pregnant four weeks and then
she kills off that's the like the
longest in the uk it's like six weeks
it's six months in the uk months
so yeah so so it's actually crazy you
caught you gotta go child twenty four
weeks
no so so crazy crazy stat the earliest
child to survive a pregnancy is 21 weeks
and it's illegal up to 24. seriously yes
and it's free here i feel like before
she should like abort it but not after
that like that that feels wrong i didn't
as in i bought it after she's given
birth yeah well no well i'm saying the
reason i asked was because you said the
baby's not conscious till like six
months so they won't know right so when
you said that i'm thinking okay well
then it sounds like you could abort it
afterwards
i'm not baby after it's been born i
wouldn't just clear it off
um i don't know i just think i just
think like because obviously i've never
been in that position so i'm not gonna
try and like
judge how women will feel in that
position because you a lot of people
love to give that opinion on this and
that and the other but they've never
been in that situation so you can say
you believe in this but when you're in
that situation your opinions might
change completely so that's why i just
feel like everyone should just have the
choice i don't know i i don't get what
the question is so what is the question
the question is matt should men have the
choice and that's that's what that's
what i'm talking about
[Music]
um
solution i feel like it's not like it's
not it shouldn't always be like okay
just give up for adoption then i feel
like it's there's too much to debate
about for that so so i want to tell you
guys or do you have time or do you have
to go i don't know how much
okay okay okay
okay no worries no worries you guys are
actually great i really enjoy talking to
people that i have different opinions
with and like we can have a civil nice
conversation it's not it's not always
like that so really appreciate it pearl
nice to meet you nice to meet you so um
today we're asking people the question
people in london so since women have the
right to choose right we have the right
to get an abortion for free in london up
to six months
should men have the right to a financial
abortion where they can sign off their
rights and they don't have to pay child
support
i believe that's yes i believe a yes to
that and i believe
but you you need to figure out like a
tighter
schedule for how it should work like
okay um if you're not married like if
you're going to have a baby you need the
guy to sign off for before a certain
time that he's going to accept all the
financial
responsibilities for it
and then make it binding um
i think you'd have to kind of have a
real set structure to it
i don't think if you like
he goes yes yes yes and he goes actually
you know what
i've said yes and i'm gonna change my
mind i don't think it should be like
that
but i think you should definitely like
have to sign something prior to prior to
the birth
why
why do you think we have child support
because why because in my head it's like
why
are i as a woman entitled to a man's
money
it's all based on
i personally think it's a lot of it's
based around
the perception of
it's quite sexist and the perception of
the woman is the weaker sex
the woman is not as able to earn as much
that the woman's always manipulated into
a situation of having a child
so
it's their sort of
support on that level i mean when you
get to it
it's kind of um yeah it's kind of a bit
unbalanced
i agree i agree i think it's very
unbalanced do you um so do you think
abortion should be legal at all yeah i
think i think it should be i think it
should be i mean i i can always say as a
guy on some level i have benefited from
it
in different ways on certain levels
whether it being
someone
when i was much much younger you know
someone got pregnant and i think it's
wow if i think back now if that person
had a child i'd have been tied to them
for 18 plus years it wouldn't have
worked out well for me um
so i i think it should be legal but i
definitely think they should now as i'm
getting older i'm realizing there should
be a lot more education about it a
little bit more
about some of the facts of it but i
definitely think it should be always a
choice when do you think abortion should
be legal up too to be honest as a guy i
i just don't know
i've not got like a set like
right it should there's this particular
date my timeline for it i'm you know i'm
not i don't i'm a woman's woman's
personal choice i don't get that
involved i mean obviously when it's like
to the point of like nine months i'm
gonna say oh yeah week before
yeah just whip it out and get rid of it
but you know it's legal in the uk up to
six months
yes you just told me yeah you just told
me i mean to be honest
it was never really in my mind like at
my level of awareness of when when the
deadline was i think i remember it got
extended maybe
10 15 years ago got lengthened out but
yeah and did you know the earliest child
to survive a pregnancy is 21 weeks
and uh so and right now it's legal up to
24. i did not know that
i didn't know that no and did you know
that 40 of women that have had abortions
um are 40 of women getting an abortion
had two or more abortions in the past
once again another another statistic i
did i didn't know i'm just curious if
that like changes your opinion on it at
all unlike when it should be legal it
doesn't really change my opinion
but i i definitely feel that both sides
should be have been allowed to um
voice their concerns
i'm not like
if someone feels it should be illegal
they should be shouted down
i can i can see where a lot of people
are coming from i mean
the whole concept of like birth control
and abortion has definitely changed the
dynamics between men and women um well
it gives all the power to women right
yeah on a reproductive level i mean
yes
there's a lot of responsibility but it
comes well a lot of power but it comes
without the shame
and a lot of the issues of the past
because there's always a potential for
women to become pregnant and have a baby
but you know if you went back
60 60 plus years ago there's a huge
aspect of the shame and social con
social conventions
and everything else i think i think it's
what people expect
of a single movie single motherhood is a
little bit skewed from what i've seen
now from what i've seen women go through
well it seems like it's almost
incentivized to be a single mother
because you get money for it you get
money for it either through child
support or from the government
yeah
so it's like if you incentivize
something more people are going to do it
oh yeah for sure for sure i mean
there's always the trope of
if a single mother be able to get more
easily get like um flat from the council
from housing or in america it was like
if in the housing projects it was is
much easier but now it's gone from being
that just a perception of easier to
it's been rebranded to the strong
independent single mother
um i mean i personally think that
raising a child is a team sport i mean
you know ideally you need
you need both parents actively
participating to have a full
well-rounded child what laws would you
see like what laws would you like to see
in the future that would advocate for
men i'd like to see compulsory dna tests
because just
there seems to be a lot
not a lot i don't know the active
statistics but i think that would help
to clear up situations where you know
someone's getting pregnant and then they
think you know what the guy i was
sexually attracted to and i've actually
become pregnant to is not as stable as
candidate number candidate b
who i can say hey we've had a baby and
i can sort of tie down because you hear
these stories and it's you know it gets
scary so there's that i think
the contractual situation be much
clearer i think because then
you can guarantee a certain level of
rights because i've heard so many
stories from real friends
where
the relationship was going well at the
start things have broken down
then maybe they've not got married they
have no real parental rights over the
for the child so if there was like the
the whole agreement situation beforehand
then there'd be an agreement already
regarding um
visitation or
just parental rights well i've heard um
i have a friend named sarah and he
advocates for marriage contracts
that go for a certain amount of time and
you can renegotiate
yeah i mean i do remember as a my
friends
husband said oh you know
marriage is like a business and i think
it was more like different people in the
partnership take different roles
but i can see how that could i could see
how that could work but then also as
well then it's like
sure it makes it quite cold the whole
aspect of it being a contract but then i
can see the logic behind it
the logic is
strong
do you think the more our society has
focused on loved as opposed to duty that
marriage has broken down because of that
yeah because it's
well yeah i mean
i guess i mean my parents are like well
my my dad's past my mom's 76 and you
hear the story and a lot of it's duty
like making things work they eventually
they got divorced and then they came
back together
but i think a lot of the people's
versions of love is more lust uh or
infatuation and it's gonna pass
there's not a case of right we've been
brought together we've got we built
something together let's make this last
it's like oh i'm tired of you now i'm
fed up with this
let's keep it moving but you've got like
you've brought kids into the world it's
due love is overtaken duty by a long
shot i think disney has played a lot
into it because people think it's like
supposed to be this electric like fairy
tale sort of thing
yeah i mean i can't i can't i can't
speak for obviously i can't speak for
women yeah of course but you know
for guys i think because obviously
obviously i feel guys more logic based
quite often and they're kind of a bit
more pragmatic
whereas you know we're talking to lots
of different women over time it does
feel they're looking for that spark and
then you're like look you're talking
about you're on a family you're looking
for a spark but
you're 39.
[Laughter]
well
you know i mean i mean you know i don't
want to be horrible i mean there's
there's the chance this loves a young
person's game
i think like love and love being loving
is a human condition but the whole but
the living in that realm of possibility
it's more practical it's easier when
you're younger
actually i think it's to be to be really
fair when i was younger i didn't have
any idea understanding of it i think now
it's much it's much easier for a guy on
certain levels because you have more
time because for a woman it's when you
know when i was 21 and the girl was like
really hustling me like what do you want
to do where you were going i think i
would be young like relax was now i
could look back at it and go
[ __ ] she had a point because for her her
window her time her window time is very
very short i mean 90 of her eggs are
gone by 30. yeah i heard that i've had
that conversation with
a girl she was like 32 33
and she got it but you know as a guy
most girls don't really want to have
that conversation
yeah you know women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time in marriages and 90
if they're college educated so it's
really not the men's that are breaking
up the home it's the women yeah i kind
of knew that already and i've seen it
already i mean because i used to work
quite a lot for uh in the nightlife
industry so i've
people i've known for like over years
and years i've seen their patterns and
it does make me question because there's
not many guys who are like yeah jumping
up and down wanting like i really need
to get married and have this romantic
wedding and everything else i've always
what i've always thought about and then
they concede and they do it because they
feel that's that's what they need to
access this girl and give her what she
wants and then she gets bored yeah it or
all the guys are stuck in situations
where
it's just barren because the the
attraction's gone yeah
well thank you so much for
for sitting down um you're kind of red
pill i don't know if you you watch red
pill content yes love it love it
i'm bits and pieces i mean it's
i think to be honest some of it is just
it's just like what was never really
allowed to be said if you're if you've
got some experience
but you know
i always kind of um
look to still maintain some compassion
well thank you very much appreciate it
so let's take that right yeah so my body
my choice the two weeks before i'm due
can i can i get because it's earth can i
get an abortion because it's my body my
choice i mean yeah obviously really
so you you think it's possible like the
woman can do that well i'm asking if you
think it should okay like if you ask me
if it should doesn't hold it in a
subject because that's it that's like
morality now right i think like you're
saying like is it right is it wrong like
that's not that's not for me to say you
know because first of all i'm not even a
woman so i don't understand this that
really i don't understand that situation
like i haven't been pregnant you know
having a kid my body knowing if it's
alive or not i don't know any of that
stuff but like um
like it's possible she can get an
abortion whether she should or not like
i don't i don't know it's not for me to
say really and truly i'm saying should
it be legal i don't know you know i
really don't know i mean that's what
lost it probably should be legal i guess
like up to birth like up to birth a girl
can get an abortion like it should be
legal that a person can make a choice on
like if they want to take a pill but
whether it's right or wrong i don't know
about that well it wouldn't be taking a
pill so you do you know abortion
surgical abortions are after like i
don't know one two months where they
pull the baby's limbs off one by one
crush the skull and then vacuum it out
flush the wall they crush the skull
so what they do so if i was to get an
abortion two weeks before the baby like
it would be fully formed basically and
they could pull the limbs out one by one
crush the skull and vacuum it out and
then they put the baby back together on
the table to make sure they got all the
pieces well i'll say yeah like in this
case you need humanity like you need
humanity because the thing is you need
to be sensitive to the life to be able
to see if it's going through pain yeah
like you need to be like it's not
something that you can take to the law
to the court because it's something that
you have still within within you like if
you can feel like the child is going
through pain like it's kind of inhuman
to do that to make someone go through
that pain but i don't notice i don't
know the science as well so i'm kind of
ignorant when it comes to this subject
no it's okay i'm not trying to get you
in like a gotcha i'm just curious
because i hear that a lot my body my
choice but if that's the case like if
we're going to use that logic it would
have to be legal up to birth because
it's in their body
and that doesn't most people that i talk
to would agree that doesn't make sense
so then the question is where where do
we draw the line i say we draw the line
like once we know like if let's say for
example the baby is alive and it can
feel the pain
then like um i would say like in my in
my humble opinion
that
you know the human thing would do to
like let that child live a life but at
the same time like you know most people
are kind of insensitized so they
wouldn't even be able to feel it anyways
i think so
well and that's the thing
it's not conclusive like scientists
don't don't know when they feel pain
it's not there's not there's not
conflict there's gynecologists that say
like three months there's gynecologist
let's say six weeks four weeks and so
it's not necessarily conclusive so in my
end like if we don't know shouldn't we
err on the side of caution i don't know
i can't answer these questions honestly
i think i need to enlighten myself a bit
more yeah no it's okay not everyone's
really looked into it but if you ever
like look up an actual abortion
procedure i think it would actually a
lot of people would change their mind if
they saw what it looked like yeah yeah
i'll say like the last thing i'll say
right is just that people should make a
choice and what they feel is right deep
inside themselves
you know and if they feel like that baby
is alive and it you know deserves to
live then that's what they should do
but if they feel like you know like
making the baby come alive it's going to
be bad for the baby then maybe that's
what they should do instead but you know
it's down to the person on how sensitive
sensitive they are to the life within
them and um
yeah i'll just leave it at that because
i don't really know anything else really
intriguing like i need to educate myself
a bit more on this okay well thank you
so much for coming on g
um yeah i want to give a shout out to
miracle safe soil where we're just
raising awareness for an environmental
concern where mother earth she's dying
and she's um you know getting worse and
worse every year so we want to like
slowly decrease the chemicals and
increase organic content in the soil so
that we can make sure the future
generation of kids have something to eat
so it's safesource.org and you know if
we get enough people together we can
elect a government that's going to say
you know what let's think about
long-term sustainability let's think
about 10 years 20 years 30 years for the
next generation of kids to make sure you
know everyone has well-being okay you
know well thank you so much i appreciate
it
have a nice day yeah have a good one
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]